I think it's I think it's Tuesday I
think it's gonna be Tuesday good morning
Hank it's Tuesday some day at the end of
October and you just got said hello to
buy a bunch of extremely excited
nerdfighters in Phoenix Arizona who were
only able to say hello to you because of
my awesome new camcorder I am so excited
about my new camcorder here Hank let me
show it to you oh oh wait if I move the
camcorder it yeah am I gonna take a
picture of the camcorder using camcorder
dang it okay Hank so you might remember
that in my last video I asked the
nerdfighters what I could do for them
after they did all this awesome stuff
for me including getting Paper Towns on
the New York Times bestseller list and
it turns out that the nerdfighters do
indeed have some requests I think you
should do NaNoWriMo in November which is
National Novel Writing Month
unfortunately despite getting down on my
knees every night and praying that God
turned me into James Patterson I'm not
able to write a novel in a month however
in the month of November I am
considering national finish a revision
of your book I mean seriously come on
month also known as Napa Rob em skull
the only problem with that is that
November is also national drive around
America with your brother month or nada
we've mow so I'm definitely going to do
nada we've mow and I'm gonna try to do
Napa Roy Pimm's gum and I apologize in
advance that it's going to be totally
impossible to do NaNoWriMo make sure
when they make a movie of Paper Towns
they don't ruin it okay you're not going
to like the way I respond to that
request first I don't think that they
can ruin a book with a movie like no
matter how unconvincing Sean Penn's
Louisiana accent sounds all the king's
men is still a great book also I ascribe
to the belief that in order to properly
adapt a book into a film you have to
radically change like everything about
the book sorry
perfect our chemistry says you can repay
us by promoting literature online and
also in schools everywhere it's funny
you should bring that up perfect our
chemistry so Hank today I was in a high
school in Seattle trying to get the kids
excited about reading talking about
books and why they still matter and blah
blah blah and um pretty much during my
entire presentation there was a lot of
like laughter and I didn't know exactly
what they were laughing at I was like I
guess I am just one funny guy and then
about 45 minutes into my one-hour talk I
opened it up for questions and like 30
hands showed up which is a little bit
unusual so I called on someone and there
like um yes mr. green are you aware of
the fact that your zipper is like
flagrantly almost obscenely unzipped oh
no I didn't but I did Hank I gave my
entire speech about the importance of
imagining other people complexly with
like a massively unzipped zipper can you
just like give me a hug you're just like
a giant teddy bear and I just love you
did you have to say that I'm like a
giant teddy bear couldn't you have just
said I'm like a regular teddy bear look
I know that the Weight Watchers hasn't
gone well you try eating on the road
it's hard out here for a touring author
it would be awesome if you went on a
national campaign to make skydiving
legal for minors I mean ain't knowing
what you do about me can you imagine a
campaign that I am less likely to go on
I don't think skydiving should be legal
for anyone it's crazy you shouldn't jump
out of a plane planes are first staying
in make my Walmart get Paper Towns it's
actually an exceptionally bad idea to
buy your books at Walmart because if
everyone buys their books at Walmart
then we're looking at a future when
about 30 to 50 books will be published
each year which would have kind of a
chilling effect on American cultural
discourse plus it would put me out of a
job because Walmart thinks my books are
too dirty to stock so Hank it was
starting to look like there was nothing
the nerdfighters wanted me to do that I
could do for them I mean I can't do
NaNoWriMo because I don't have time my
conscience won't allow me to advocate
for minors skydiving because I think
it's a terrible idea and I can't get my
books in Walmart because I'm too dirty
but didn't finally Hank I saw fulfil
Abul request could you record yourself
doing your happy dance for us in 18
different states yes I can my zipper is
unzipped dang it Hank I'll see you in
just a few minutes at the amazing
Seattle Public Library